Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is the amazing ChatGPT, a
variant of the GPT-3 language
model AI that was unleashed
to read the internet and now,
we can use it as a conversational agent. And
today, we can even subject it to an IQ test.
In a previous episode, we saw that
it could write new song lyrics,
or even give us ideas for designing a living
room. However, you see, this is a language model,
so it can only give us text. Not images. However,
no one said that we cannot plug in these text
prompts into a text to image AI, so these Fellow
Scholars did just that. And thus, we could even
see these beautiful results come to life. This
was one of my favorite examples, and it turns out,
we can even get ChatGPT to give us some beautiful
imagery with some other tricks. And it can do
even more. Here are 5 more amazing examples that I
absolutely adore and would love to share with you.
One, we can ask it to create the description of
an SVG file, which is a vector image format. This
describes in text what kinds of objects go where.
And, are you thinking what I am thinking? Oh yes,
this is an excellent way of using text to
create images. So it can create this red circle,
blue triangle, or even a face. Now if you
think that it is all it can do, then have a
look at this. For instance, can it create a vector
version of the Twitter logo? Wow, it can. So cool!
Okay, okay, but I am a computer
graphics researcher by trade,
so I would love to see something a little more
advanced. So what other piece of text is there
that can create absolutely beautiful images? Of
course, computer code! And hold on to your papers,
because here it is. Two, it can write proper
pixel shaders. What is that? This is a website
called shadertoy where we can submit a piece of
computer code that is executed by our graphics
cards and produces an image. Oh yes, an even
more powerful way of taking a piece of text,
and creating beautiful images, videos, or
even a computer game with it. And ChatGPT
can even write these cool little programs
too. They compile and run well. Wow.
Now, you may be thinking, are these
just some cute little test programs,
or are they actually useful in any way? Well,
three, check this out: this example shows that it
can even write computer code to place a mirror in
our computer game. It works like this. Yet another
example of using a tool for something that it
was not designed to do. I absolutely love these.
Four, when we are talking about potential
applications in the industry, here is another one.
Whoa. ChatGPT can be asked to find, and even fix
security holes in a piece of computer code. That
is such an incredible thing because it requires
knowledge on what happens if we execute a piece of
code, and even better, what potential weaknesses
may arise. That feels like talking to an
intelligent being…until we ask it to multiply two
numbers together, and it then fails spectacularly.
It is so close! But not quite correct. The amusing
properties of a modern AI system. Loving it.
Five, so actually, how reliable is it? Well,
it is not always that unreliable. A Fellow
Scholar had ChatGPT take the SAT test, and
this, dear Fellow Scholars is just about
the SAT score for an average human. Wow.
And it can also take a linguistic IQ test,
and if you have a closer look, these questions
require a considerable English vocabulary. So,
what does this test think ChatGPT’s IQ
is? It says 147. Holy mother of papers.
Now before we get too excited, note that
these are not peer-reviewed experiments,
so I am a little hesitant to give them too
much credence, and I hope you are too. So
please don’t take these too seriously. However,
I feel that these are likely early indications
of something amazing coming up real soon. I
really hope that we will see a few peer-reviewed
papers on the academic capabilities of
ChatGPT in more rigorous tests soon.
So the original GPT was an AI that was meant to
read the internet, learn English, and maybe be
able to finish incomplete Amazon reviews. And
now it knows computer graphics programming,
cybersecurity, has lots of
general human knowledge,
and more. Just imagine what this will
be able to do a couple more papers down
the line. If you have some ideas,
let me know in the comments below!
And now, if you have a Mac computer, you can even
add it to your menu bar to access it quickly,
and for free. How cool is that? Or, plugins for
all major browsers now seem to be available too.
So, until the follow up papers appear, let
the experiments begin! ChatGPT has inspired
a lot of you Fellow Scholars all over the
world, and has reached a million users in
an incredibly small amount of time. That was
one of the most explosive transitions from a
paper to a real-world product to show everyone
that the papers are real. As real as it gets.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!